[Aplausos]
yo no quería estudiar
cuando termine mi enseñanza primaria le
dije a mi padre ya no quiero ir a la
escuela inscribirme mejor en la academia
para secretarias de aquí del pueblo y él
me dijo como quieras
fue me inscribió cuando regreso con la
boleta en la mano
me dijo el lunes te presentas porque ya
empiezan las clases mi madre que estaba
a un lado
volteó inmediatamente
y le dijo no
juan va a ir a la secundaria
hay que inscribirlo él tiene que
estudiar para hacer alguien en la vida
y así fue
llegué a la secundaria y de ahí pasé a
la preparatoria y luego me fui a la
ciudad de mexico a estudiar la
licenciatura en periodismo y después
hacer un posgrado a españa'
sin embargo
esa frase
y ese momento transformaron mi vida me
enseñaron
que hay que prepararse
para enfrentar los retos y los desafíos
los retos que nos presenta el mundo
moderno
recuerden ustedes
la perestroika
la caída del muro de berlín y el final
de la guerra fría
la llegada del primer presidente de
origen afroamericano a la presidencia de
los eeuu y aquí en méxico también las
crisis recurrentes que hemos vivido las
devaluaciones y las modificaciones del
sistema político mexicano
y qué decir de la tecnología cómo ha
cambiado cómo ha revolucionado a la
sociedad moderna y ha impuesto nuevos
paradigmas nuevas formas de comunicar
nuevas formas de informar
por ejemplo
antes no existía la telefonía móvil
y menos aún los textos telefónico
les voy a compartir una anécdota
cuando miro la telefonía móvil y los
textos a este sistema pocos podían
enviar mensajes de texto
yo le pedí a un muchacho que trabajaba
conmigo era mi colaborador le pedí que
me enseñara a enviar mensajes y me dijo
es muy fácil permítame su aparato le
pico
me dijo envié el mensaje
hágalo todos los días
el primer mensaje que envié se lo mandé
a un amigo a los dos minutos me estaba
llamando por teléfono
como lo hiciste
y como decían nuestros abuelos cuando
eran sorprendidos le dije es cosa del
y es que las tecnologías han
revolucionado totalmente las formas de
comunicación
hoy internet por ejemplo ha borrado
prácticamente al correo tradicional
el cartero es una especie en peligro de
extinción
ya todo se hace a través de mensajes vía
electrónica y el dinero también ha
cambiado antes cuando cobrábamos nuestra
quincena o nuestra semana nos daban un
sobre con nuestro dinero nuestro pago
hoy nos dan una tarjeta de plástico y
con eso hacemos todo ahí están todos los
datos todas nuestras finanzas nuestros
ahorros nuestros créditos todo está ahí
si queremos efectivo vamos a un cajero
automático y de ahí extraemos la
cantidad que queremos
el verbo text jr no existía hoy es lo
más común
y seguramente habrá una modificación en
la real academia de la lengua para
incorporar esta nueva palabra y qué
decir de los medios de comunicación
han sufrido una transformación
impresionante
los medios tradicionales prensa radio y
televisión hoy no solamente han sufrido
los embates de estos cambios sino que
están en una severa crisis poca
audiencia escasos lectores
pocas ventas despido de trabajadores
desaparición de algunos medios y de
algunas cadenas
enormes internacionales
y en contraparte
las plataformas digitales el periodismo
digital y las redes sociales avanzan
impresionantemente
menos costo más ventas cantidades
millonarias
y ha surgido una nueva generación una
nueva especie diría yo el bloguero
jóvenes chicos y chicas que tienen una
gran influencia
en el turismo
en el entretenimiento en la información
y saben qué
solamente utilizan un teléfono móvil
eso es todo
hoy los reporteros
hacen sus coberturas sus entrevistas
toman fotografías graban vídeo
transmiten en vivo editan audio editan
vídeo producen podcasts
todo eso hace
un solo reportero un solo periodista
estos son los cambios que estamos
enfrentando hoy
y si yo no hubiera estudiado
si no me hubiera preparado
estas transformaciones me hubieran
aplastado
y no me hubieran dejado salir adelante
estaría confinado
en una oficina frente a un escritorio y
probablemente me hubieran despedido hace
ya muchos años
pero estos retos estos desafíos
nos obligan a prepararnos
a estudiar todos los días
actualizarnos a estar mejor informados a
monitorear todos los medios de
comunicación en el caso mío como
informador
y como dijo alvin toffler a subirnos a
la ola del cambio
sobre todo
estos estas migraciones me han permitido
a mí ya muchos de mi generación
y disfrutar el mundo que hoy vivimos
y algo muy importante que debemos de
tener en frente de todos hombres y
mujeres adultos y jóvenes
arrebatar el éxito es así como los
millennials de 60 años nos hemos
preparado para esta nueva ola del cambio
en la sociedad moderna gracias por estar
esta noche
[Aplausos]